oh wow denise
you got to be kidding
hoarders
they can't bear to throw anything away
they pile up stuff
everywhere cluttering every space until
they can't move anymore oh my god
what if we could flip a switch in
people's brains so they would never want
to throw anything away
would hoarding impact our economy
would we need to build bigger homes
and
how would you organize all your garbage
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you never threw anything away
[Music]
hoarding is a disorder and it's no joke
it's associated with perfectionism and a
fear of making wrong decisions
and it can drag people into depression
anxiety attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder and alcoholism
hoarding can cause problems in
relationships this is not
garbage you're insane it creates health
and safety concerns including fire and
tripping hazards
studies have linked hoarding to abnormal
activity in specific areas of the
brain's cortex
the brain isn't able to decide how
important or relevant items are
including whether or not to hold on to
garbage and keeping garbage in your home
would harm your health accumulating
garbage could lead to bacteria viruses
diseases and infestations
[Music]
we don't want to become hoarders but
what if all the world's governments
passed a law stating that we had to keep
everything we bought
forever
no more garbage collection
burning or dumping stuff
take this box of macaroni and cheese
it feeds you for just one meal but you
would be stuck with the box and the
plastic bag
for the rest of your life you might
think twice about buying it how would
keeping everything impact your habits
if you had to keep everything you bought
you'd need to become more thoughtful
resourceful and healthy you might say
goodbye to plastic bags and choose
reusable shopping bags
restaurants would offer reusable
takeaway containers or people might need
to bring their own people wouldn't want
single-use plastics and the packaging
industry would have to adapt or die it's
more likely that we would consume fresh
food more often that would be good for
our oceans landfills and environment as
a whole all your bills letters and mail
would be written and delivered
electronically you'd probably keep your
favorite books and maybe you'd give the
rest away new books would only be
available in electronic formats the
repair industry would skyrocket and so
would do it yourself activities imagine
building your own kitchen or that deck
you've always wanted for the backyard
people might start borrowing or trading
goods instead of buying new hey is there
any chance you have a mini refrigerator
no okay
we wouldn't be as obsessed with
upgrading our homes and buying new
things and we might end up saving money
that we could spend on experiences
instead of things i'm
obsessed with this we might also build
bigger houses to accommodate more stuff
and why not be creative and use our
garbage and leftover items to do that
in 2014
researchers at the university of
brighton built a two-story home 85
percent of it was made from waste
including bicycle inner tubes vhs tapes
and even used toothbrushes are you still
thinking about how to get rid of your
old stuff or maybe you really want to
buy some new clothes
for many people
shopping feels good sometimes it makes
their day but let's be honest you likely
wear twenty percent of your wardrobe
eighty percent of the time and that's
true for almost everything we buy as
consumers we are responsible for more
than 60 percent of greenhouse gas
emissions and up to 80 percent of the
world's water use and we know what
that's doing to the environment we could
change our economies so that they're not
based on consumerism or buying new goods
and we could make better use of what we
already have
that could change our world for the
better like instead of buying christmas
trees and throwing them away each year
what would happen if we grew our own
christmas trees
well that's a story for another what if
[Music]
you